- La vision double, la vision
trouble. C'était étourdissant.
Ça me donnait des vertiges,
la nausée intense. Et la,
je savais qu'il y avait
de quoi de pas normal.
- Josée Laroche a contracté
la COVID au début de la pandémie
alors qu'elle était bénévole
dans un CHSLD. Dans les mois qui
ont suivi, elle a eu de graves
problèmes de santé :
fibromyalgie, fatigue extrême,
perte de poids et d'appéti
puis des difficultés avec sa
vision et une soif constante.
JOSÉE LAROCHE
- Plus ça allait, leisisis
passaient, la bouche sèche.
Je me levais le matin et j'avais
terriblement soif, mais une soif
anormale que javavavais jamais
eue auparavant.
- Après plusieurs consultations,
le diagnostic qu'elle craignait
est to: : : en diabète
de type 2.
- Mon père a quand même
le diabète. Et quand
uiuiuiui en parlait, il disait :
"Ça ressemble pas mal
aux symptômes que moi, j'ai."
- Après les poumons, le coeur,
le cerveau et le foie,
on constate maintenant que le
coronavirus peut aussi attaquer
le pancréas, ce qui conduit
parfois au développement
d'un diabète.
Dr RÉMI RABASA-LHORET,
endrocrinologue
- On sait que la COVID, le
de la COVID peut infecter
directement les cellules
qui sont dans le pancréaset qui,
qui sont absolument essentielle
pour régler la glycémie.
- Le cas de madame Laroche n'est
pas exceptionnel, au contraire.
Une étude récente des données
médicales de 200 000 personnes
touchées par la COVID démontre
qu'une simple infection
augmente le risque de développer
un diabète de type 2 de 40 %
et de 300 % si on a dû être
hospitalisé.
- Je pense qu'il ne reste pas
impossible que la COVID augmente
le risque de développer
le diabète, mais ce qui est déjà
établi, probablement à ce
jour-là, à la fois par les
études et par l'expérience
clinique, c'est que la COVID
accélère le risque de diabète
chez les gens prédisposés,
chez une fraction des gens
prédisposés très probablement.
- Le problème, c'est qu'il y a
énormément de gens qui sont
prédiabétiques, souvent sans
savoir. Aux États-Unis, on parle
de 38 % de la population
et au Canada de 22 %. Même si
seulement une petite fraction
de ces gens-là développent
un diabète précocement,
il y aura une hausse
substantielle des cas et
des demandes de consultations,
estime le Docteur Rabasa-Lhoret.
- Le problème majeur qu'on a eu
dans ces deux dernières années,
c'est le nombre de personnes
qui ont été diagnostiqués
avec un nouveau cas de diabète,
qui font partie des nombreux
Québécois, malheureusement
orphelins de médecins de famille
et qui n'arrivent pas à être
pris en charge.
- En théorie, il est possible
qu'un diabète déclenché par la
COVID régresse avec le t
Mais pour sa part,
Josée Laroche a fait son deuil.
- On m'a parlé de me préparer
mentalement à ce
touchée pour le restant
de mes jours.
- Cependant, malgré ses nombreux
problèmeelelelelelelelle ne
regrette pas d'avoir offert son
aide quand les CHSLD en avaient
le plus grand besoin.
- J'ai tenu la main d'aînés
qui étaient terrifiés de mourir
avec la COVID. C'était
crève-coeur. Je regrette pas le
temps que je leur ai donné ici.
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal